>> Jesse: HE IS A NEW SHOW
PREMIERING ON FOX NATION THAT
TAKES THE FIGHT TO
CANCEL CULTURE.
HERE IS MORGAN UNCENSORED TO
CELEBRATE FREE SPEECH WITH A
LIVELY DEBATE AND AGENDA SETTING
INTERVIEWS YOU DESCRIBE YOURSELF
WITH A VERY COLORFUL WAY.
HOW DID YOU DESCRIBE YOURSELF?
>> IT'S CAN BE AIRING IN THE
U.S. EVERY NIGHT, AUSTRALIA
EVERY NIGHT, I'M NOW OFFICIALLY
WHAT OF ALWAYS WANTED TO BE A
GLOBAL IRRITANT.
I WANT TO IRRITATE ALL THE RIGHT
PEOPLE COME ALL THE PEOPLE THAT
WE ALL FIND UNIQUELY IRRITATING.
IT'S IS PERMANENTLY OFFENDED
SNOWFLAKE E CANCEL CULTURE MODEL
THAT DESCENDS LIKE A PACK OF
HORNETS ON ANYTHING THEY CAN GET
THEMSELVES INTO.
TRYING TO SUPPRESS EVERYONE'S
RIGHT TO AN OPINION, TRYING TO
TELL US ALL HOW TO THINK, HOW TO
ACT HOW TO LEFT OR WHAT STONY,
WHAT PARTS OF HISTORY ARE
ACCEPTABLE AND WHAT AREN'T.
I THINK WERE ALL JUST SICK AND
TIRED OF IT.
WHAT THEY WERE IN NEW YORK,
LONDON, SYDNEY, EVERYONE IS FED
UP WITH THIS FED UP WITH THIS
SMALL VOCAL PERMANENTLY ANGRY
HUMORLESS HORRIBLE GROUP OF
PEOPLE.
THIS AWOKE BRIGADE I DON'T MEAN
THE ORIGINAL INTERPRETATION ON
IT WHICH MEANT JUST TO BE MORE
SOCIALLY AWARE SOCIAL RACIAL
INJUSTICE MEAN THIS NEW CREATION
OF THE WOKE CANCEL CULTURE OR
JUST SOMEBODY WHO BELIEVES THAT
THEIR OPINION IS NOT JUST THE
ONLY ONE THAT CAN BE TOLERATED,
THAT ANYONE THAT DEVIATES ONE
IOTA FROM THAT OPINION HAS TO BE
DESTROYED SHAMED, ABUSED AND
THEN CANCELED HAVE THE JOB TAKEN
AWAY FROM THEM THEIR LIVELIHOODS
WRECKED SIBLEY FOR HAVING A
DIFFERENT OPINION I THINK THE
WORLD HAS BECOME A SMALL PLACE
IN TERMS OF DEBATE WERE HAVING
THIS SAME'S ARGUMENTS AROUND THE
WORLD ABOUT.
I THINK THE VAST MAJORITY OF
PEOPLE WHETHER IT'S AMERICA,
U.K., AUSTRALIA, OR OTHER
COUNTRIES.
THE VAST MAJORITY WITH ME AND I
EXPECT WITH THE PANEL HERE THAT
THIS HAS GONE WAY TOO FAR AND
THE FREE SPEECH HAS TO MEAN
WHAT'S FREE SPEECH MEANS AND
THAT DOESN'T JUST MEAN THAT YOU
TOLERATE OPINIONS YOU AGREE
WITH.
ACTUALLY MEANS THE OPPOSITE,
WINSTON CHURCHILL SAID LISTENING
TO PEOPLE WHOSE OPINIONS YOU
FAIRLY DISAGREE WITH, BUT YOU
TOLERATE ANY RESPECT.
>> Jesse: EIGEN ALLOWED THEM
TO DROP WINSTON CHURCHILL QUOTES
UN-AMERICAN SHOW?
IF YOU DON'T KNOW WALK OFF.
>> Greg: WHEN YOU INVITE ME TO
BE ON YOUR SHOW I ASSUME I'LL BE
FLOWN FIRST CLASS.
>> THANK YOU ALL TAKE THAT AS A
GUEST YOU WILL BE INVITED
OBVIOUSLY SO YOUR YOUR SHOW
SHARES THE SAME THING THAT WE
ALL FEEL THE SAME WAY RIGHT?
>> Dana: ONE INTERVIEW PER
SHOW?
>> WE MIGHT TAKE LIKE THIS SHOW.
I WILL HAVE PEOPLE FROM ALL
SIDES OF THE POLITICAL DIVIDE, I
WANT TO GET BACK TO WHAT USED TO
BE LIKE WHEN YOU HAVE IT AN
ARGUMENT WITH A GOOD FRIEND
ABOUT SOME ISSUE IN THE NEWS AND
YOU CAN AFTERWARD SO GET A BEER
AFTERWARDS.
[LAUGHS]
THERE ARE SOME EXCEPTIONS.
I CAN ONLY THINK THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE FOR TAKEN ABACK.
[LAUGH